okay next caller is from the 907 area
code caller from 907 who's there what's
on your mind today
9 1 7 you might have us muted take us
off mute if that's the case 9 1 7 last
opportunity I'm gonna have to hang there
is 9 1 7 all of a sudden what did you
have us on mute uh sorry you can hear me
now yes I can okay I'm sorry
hi I'm calling about the Ilhan Omar
controversy in particular and the way in
which the progressive media talks about
anti-semitism concerns by the Jewish
community in general I have been you
know I listen to a lot of the sort of
progressive media that you're served in
that in that sphere and there's been
this narrative about the concern over
Ilhan Omar's comments recently that this
is all a mere campaign that it is rooted
either they say this explicitly or
implicitly in and Islamophobic you know
attack on who she is is sort of part of
some like white supremacist whatever and
listening to that media as somebody who
shares the concerns that people have
voiced about her comment and about
things in like the Labour Party in
Britain and other things has been a
really emotionally distressing
experience because this is not a smear
campaign there are people who are
genuinely concerned about something and
I understand if people who are not sort
of attuned to the tropes of
anti-semitism and the way that that
plays into a politics don't understand
why people are upset but it they they
can sit down and have a good-faith
discussion rather than attacking it I
mean I wonder as somebody who seems to
sort of understand where these concerns
are coming from how you think one ought
to address and how you are maybe
interested in addressing these
narratives in the progressive media
about what's going on sorry it's like if
I went on for little to longer okay so
here's here's how I would approach it
you're absolutely right that there are
people on both sides who are just having
bad faith conversations and let me let
me give you one example you have for
example
I as a Jewish person when I said hey you
know I don't think that her tweets are
evidence of anti-semitism I don't think
that her tweets are evidence of
deliberately perpetuating anti-semitic
tropes but I think that they really
weren't well thought out and
inadvertently refer to some of those
anti-semitic tropes which is a pretty
even comment right I'm saying I'm not
accusing her of anti-semitism or
anything but here's where I think that
she might have kind of stuck her foot in
her mouth I'm immediately told that I'm
a shill who is biased by being Jewish
and therefore my opinion is effectively
zeroed out on this issue now if I wanted
to argue in bad faith the equivalent
would be for me to tell anyone who's not
Jewish you don't know what you're
talking about because you're not Jewish
you simply don't have all of the
information that would be required
because anti-semitism isn't something
that you've studied in detail for your
entire life you're the one who simply
lacks the information to even assess
this situation like I could say that but
I think I would be acting in bad faith
why do I say that that would be in bad
faith we would all be much better off if
when we get into this type of
disagreement we say okay rather than a
tributing subterfuge or some kind of
secret agenda to the other person be the
agenda Islamophobia or pro-israeli bias
or whatever let's assume that the other
person is arguing in good faith and
let's figure out how they came to that
conclusion that I think would be a much
better way of starting an in good faith
conversation rather than smearing the
opposition or attributing you know
secret motives to what it is that has
gotten them to where they are and noting
very few people are actually willing to
do that and can I ask quickly um is
there why do you think I mean like when
I see this I'm coming from the
perspective of like having also followed
you know seven people resign seven
Jewish members of the Labor Party
Labour Party resigned recently because
of anti-semitism
and they're like this is a very real
phenomenon and it seems that people I
mean like I mean we can point to
particular progressive shows on YouTube
that have talked about this are entirely
unwilling to accept the idea that Jews
are in good faith concerned about
anti-semitism and when when in fact like
if you listen to the way that either
Ilhan Omar specifically or the people
who defend her talk about the allegation
there's this constant suggestion of even
if you don't realize you're being
Islamophobic you actually are and I
totally am open to the possibility that
I harbor a bias I'm not aware of I think
that's part of being a progressive
person in this age is recognizing sure
you might have prejudices that are
internalized and yet nobody seems
willing to do that same self-criticism
in the context of anti-semitism and that
seems like a really deep problem that
there's this one prejudicial blind spot
that no one will acknowledge yep and
listen if you can be unconsciously
Islamophobic then of course you can be
unconsciously anti-semitic and so
dismissing that conceptually is
logically fallacious but here let me
mint I'll say this as I get ready to
move on if you want evidence of how many
people are arguing in bad faith on this
issue we're gonna take this call that is
wrapping up now we're gonna put it on
YouTube you and I had a conversation
about how can we get people to have more
meaningful and substantive conversations
how can we solve problems
there's no reason whatsoever that
somebody should see this clip and be
furious but it is going to be riddled
with both dislikes on YouTube and
absolutely horrible comments and there's
absolutely no reason for it and and that
will be the proof of exactly what it is
you're describing great thank you so
much all right appreciate the call thank
you so much